we've seen in several videos so far that
most of the ways that humans haven't
have encountered in nature waves in the
water or sound waves or just waves
traveling along a rope
they were disturbances traveling through
a medium and so when light displays or
has wave-like properties a very natural
assumption was well light must also be a
disturbance traveling through some type
of a medium even if that medium wasn't
so easy to detect but they conjectured
that there is some type of medium that
light is a disturbance traveling through
they called it the luminiferous ether
and much of physics in the 19th century
was all around proving that the
luminiferous ether existed and also
figuring out what our relative velocity
was relative what our relative velocity
was in regards to that luminiferous
ether and why do we feel confident or
why did they feel confident that there
was a relative velocity what we talked
about that in the last video the earth
is spinning and then it's spinning
around the it's orbiting around the Sun
at a nice clip and then the whole solar
system is orbiting around the center of
the galaxy at a nice clip the galaxy
itself might be moving so if you have
some absolute frame of reference that's
defined by the ether well we are going
to be moving relative to it and if you
say like if we're moving relative to it
well maybe you just measure the speed of
light in different directions and see
whether the speed of light is faster or
slower in a certain direction and then
that might help you identify well one
validate that the ether exists but also
think about what our what our velocity
is relative to the ether relative to
that absolute frame of reference but the
problem in the nineteenth century is
that we did not have any precise way of
actually measuring or precise enough way
of measuring the speed of light where we
could detect the relative difference due
to go the light going for or against or
into or way from the actual direction of
the ether wind and so the experiment
that is usually cited with first kind of
breaking things open starting to really
make a dent in this whole idea of a
luminous
ether is the michelson-morley experiment
Michael sin worldly experiment they
recognize okay we can't measure the
speed of light with enough precision to
detect has it gotten slowed down by the
ether wind or sped up by the ether wind
but what we could do and this is what
Michelson and Morley did do and I'm
going to do a verse implication of the
experiment and it said okay you have a
light source you have a light source
right over here so you have a light
source and so that's going to send light
in this direction it's going to send
light just like that and what you do is
you have a half-silvered mirror that
allows half the light to pass directly
through it and half of it to be
reflected so let's put a half-silvered
mirror right over here so there's a
half-silvered mirror and so half of this
light will bounce off like this this is
just a simplification of it let me do it
a little neater than that
so half will bounce off like that and
then the other half will be able to go
through it will being able to go through
it it's a half-silvered mirror and then
we make each of those light rays we've
essentially taken our original light
rain split it into two
well then we'll then bounce those off
mirrors bounce those off mirrors that
are equidistant and there are some
adjustments when you actually have to
factor in everything but just as a
simple notion these things are just now
going to bounce back so this one is now
going to bounce back it's how silvered
it can go through or part of it can go
through that mirror so that's that ray
and then this one is going to bounce
back this one's going to go bounce back
and part of it is going to bounce into
this direction and then you can detect
what you see you can detect what you see
so this right over here is a detector
and you might be saying okay Sal well
what's the big deal you've taken a light
source you bounced you split the light
rays you've put them back together
you've bounced them around a little bit
but think about if there was a
luminiferous if either these light waves
that are going in orthogonal direction
we'll be going at different velocities
let's say if that luminiferous ether if
that luminiferous ether was if the ether
wind was doing something like let me see
if the ether wind were in this direction
if the ether wind were in that direction
when the light wave is going that way it
should be going faster and when the
light wave is coming back it should be
going it should be going slower and so
what Mickelson and Morley did is is okay
let's assume let's just if let's adjust
our apparatus right over here so when
these two light rays bounce off then
come back together if there were no
ether you would have some basic
interference pattern so what do I mean
by interference pattern well let's say
that you have maybe this one bouncing
from up here let me do that in a
different color so the one bouncing from
the one bouncing from up here let's say
that that is looks like this I'll just
draw it as a longitudinal wave just like
this best I hand hand-drawn longitudinal
wave and then the one coming from the
other direction the one that bounces
here and then comes back like this is
another longitudinal wave like this and
when they overlap they are going to
interfere with each other either
constructively interfere or
destructively interfere so you could
have something like you could have
something like this so let me copy and
then let me paste it so depending on how
far how fast each of these traveled
you're going to have different levels of
interference and you would have a
difference depending on the orientation
depending on what the actual ether wind
is doing but what Mickelson and Morley
observed is that no matter how they
oriented this apparatus and then it at
different times of the year and they
rotated around and they rotated in the
in the vertical direction in the
horizontal direction no matter what they
did they always got the same
interference pattern the interference
pattern did not change and because the
interference pattern did not change it
implied that well maybe this ether isn't
really having a
effect on slowing down or speeding up
the light waves so this was an it is
often called one of the most famous
failed experiments in physics so let me
write this now what's powerful about it
is that it was a failed experiment let
me get my pin tool out it was a failed
failed experiment but it made people
start to question well maybe there isn't
an either an luminiferous ether maybe
light just somehow travels through the
vacuum maybe there is not this absolute
frame of reference this is defined by
the luminiferous ether and I want to be
clear it wasn't this experiment by
itself this experiment was one of many
that started to put that doubt but even
after this experiment and they saw that
there was no change no matter how in the
interference pattern no matter how they
oriented this thing whether it was going
in the direction of the luminaire the
hypothetical luminiferous ether are away
from it or whatever when they saw no
matter how they oriented that they get
the same interference patterns people
try to come up with other explanations
that still might have been okay with a
luminiferous ether maybe the length got
contracted in the direction of the
motion
maybe other things got affected but this
is a super important experiment in
physics because once again it started to
show that hey maybe there is no
luminiferous ether that light is just
going to go through that vacuum and as
we'll see it's going to be traveling at
the same velocity no matter what frame
of reference you look at it from but
we'll explore that more in future videos